اذا كنت تعرف الرقم الفرعي ادخله الان
الفنانين احييكم اجمل تحيه وادعوكم لسماع
باقه جديده من اغنيتكم نرجو محاوله
الاتصال في وقت لاحق
[موسيقى]
الكاميرا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم ايها الساده
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
جاءنا البيان التالي الحمد لله وحده
والصلاه والسلام على من لا نبي بعده وبعد
فقد ثبت لدى المحكمه العليا دخول شهر
رمضان المبارك هذه الليله وعليه يكون يوم
غد هو الاول من شهر رمضان المبارك لهذا
العام جعله الله هالا بالخير والبركات
ونسال الله لعموم المسلمين التوفيق
والسداد وصلى الله وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
[موسيقى]
الدكتور سليمان بن محمد العيدي وكيل وزاره
الاعلام لشؤون التلفزيون عملت في مجال
الاذاعه والتلفزيون على ما يزيد عن اربعين
عاما اقدم مثل هذا اللون
الاعلامي للمشاهدين على فتره لا تقل عن
عشرين سنه تقريبا وهم كلهم يترقبون اذا
جاء الهلال جاء العيد اذا جاء العيد جاء
العيد جاء رمضان فنخرج ونقول البيانات
الحقيقه اللي عرف يسمونه بيان من الديوان
الملكي وهو بيان مبني على ما راته المحكمه
العليا في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
يستقبل المسلمون صباح غد الاحد اول ايام
عيد الفطر المبارك بعد اكتمال شهر رمضان
المبارك لعام
1441 للهجره تقبل الله منا ومنكم صالح
العمل وكل عام وانتم بخير الهوايه لعبت
دور كبير جدا في عشقي للمايكروفون وعشقي
للاذاعه
في مراحل مبكره كنت في المرحله الثانويه
من دراستي كنت اسجل في الاذاعه والتلفزيون
عبر الكاسيت واسمع صوتي واسجل نشرات
الاخبار من الاذاعه والتلفزيون تنمت هذه
الموهبه حتى بعد ما تخرجت من في عام
19878 ميلادي عام
1998 للهجره
ذهبت الى الاذاعه والى التلفزيون وانا
مسلح حقيقه بهذه الموهبه قبلت مذيعا وعشت
ما يفوق من اربعه عقود لله الحمد
جمله صغيره كانت هي اذاعه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه من الرياض
ايها المستمعون الكرام السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله تعالى وبركاته انا ارتبطت مع
المشاهدين او المستمعين والمشاهدين بثلاثه
امور من يعني متعلقه بشهر رمضان المبارك
اولها مسابقه رمضان للكبار الى حلقه جديده
من حلقات مسابقه رمضان للكبار لهذا العام
الثانيه النقل المباشر من الحرم المكي
الشريف قبيل اذان المغرب الثالثه النقل
المباشر من صعيد عرفات في ايام الحج
ايها المشاهدون الكرام
في مشهد ايماني روحاني
يرتبط بقلب كل مسلم في هذا اليوم الفضيل
في يوم عرفه هذه المجموعه جعلت الاذن
بالنسبه للمستمع والمشاهد تعلق او تتعلق
بصوت سليمان العيدي ولذلك رمضان بالذات
شهر رمضان المبارك عشنا معه حوالي قرابه
ايضا 17 سنه الى 20 سنه في مسابقه اسمها
مسابقه رمضان للكبار ما قصه هذه المسابقه
قصه المسابقه انها ليست يعني طارئه وانما
هي من بدايات التلفزيون وجدت هذا اللون
لكن طورت يعني في 14
في عام 88 و 89 تحولت من التسجيل الصوتي
الى البث المباشر في تقريبا
1996 بدانا ننقل المسابقه من الصوتيات الى
المشاهد عبر برامج بث مباشر للتقنيه تغيرت
كانت اول الناس المسابقات هذه ترى كانت
عبر الرسائل تكتب باليد والناس شؤونها
وينتظرون سته اشهر اربعه اشهر حتى تخرج
النتائج اليوم لا المسابقات كلها عبر
الاتصالات الفضائيه والاتصال المرئي
والسرعه الالقاء اصبحت ناخذ النتائج لايف
يعني مباشر تعلن نتائجها في نفس الليله كل
ما يتعلق بالقران الكريم كل سنه نقدم 30
حلقه على سبيل المثال طبيعه السؤال ما هو
كيف نساله السؤال الاول
من علماء بني اسرائيل ومن احبارهم
اماته الله مائه عام ثم بعث ورد ذكره في
القران الكريم
فمن هو وبعد ذلك ننتظر 24 ساعه نتلقى
الاجابات من المشاهدين والفائز فائز اكثر
من ثلاثه ملايين ريال مجموع المسابقه او
جوائز المسابقه اعيد مره اخرى اكثر من
ثلاثه ملايين ريال جوائز المسابقه مع كتاب
الله سبحانه وتعالى سنعود اليكم بعد قليل
مسابقه كانت تقدم بعد العصر
ومره اخرى قدمناها بعد المغرب ومره
قدمناها بعد صلاه التراويح من الحرم المكي
الشريف فهي متنقله حسب هيكل البرامج
التلفزيوني الذي يقر ومع ذلك يعني ثلاثين
يوم انت بعيد عن الاسره من المواقف التي
لا تنسى بما ان نسمي يعني سليمان العيدي
كانت اخر حلقه يوم 29 رمضان
وغدا انا اعلن العيد
فقبل البرنامج ما ينتهي بدقيقه
احد المشاهدين معي على الهوى
في اخر المسابقه يقول يعني اقول له يعني
انت الان عارف الاجابه قال لا انا ما عرفت
الاجابه لكن انا اعرف انه اليوم انت عيد
وبكره عيد عيدني يا اخي اعطيني الجائزه يا
اخي فقلت له انت فايز بالفين ريال مبروك
عليك لجنه المسابقه تقول امنحه لانه كان
اخر متصل في تلك الليله من ليالي رمضان
وكان بكره عيد فكان شكرا يا عيدي على
عيديتك وكذا اجمل القصص التي لا انساها في
حياتي الاتصالات السعوديه اول ما بدات في
الثمانينات كنا نسجل صوت ان الرقم الذي
طلبته وغير موجوده في الخدمه مؤقتا فضلا
تاكد من الرقم الصحيح وشكرا فيوم من
الايام انا بجوار والدتي وهي تتصل بمنزل
اخي فطلع الصوت هذا عليها فكانها ارادت ان
تشتم انه يعني هذا وش هذا اللي يقول
الكلام هذا فقلت ترى هذا سليمان قالت
استغفر الله استغفر الله
يعني موقف لا ينسى الصوت بالنسبه لي يعني
هو هو
مفتاح للتواصل مع اشخاص عشت معهم في حياتي
يعني من من من لا يذكر الاستاذ ماجد الشبل
احد مذيعي الدول العربيه وهو في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
قال الله تعالى واذا قرئ القران فاستمعوا
له وانصتوا لعلكم ترحمون صدق الله العظيم
مع نهايه هذا اللقاء ارجو ان تكونوا قد
استمتعتم ونسال الله في نهايته ان يحفظ
بلادنا وان يوفقنا جميعا بما فيه الخير
استودعكم الله جميعا ايها الاخوه
المشاهدون والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[موسيقى]